[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi à 16
février soutenir les petits face aux
gros c'est l'objectif du fonds lancé
depuis un an par la ville de maurepas un
fonds pour aider les commerçants locaux
qui souhaitent rénover leurs devantures
une boutique a déjà profité de cette
manne financière moins d'épreuves finale
est mise en place du contrôle continu et
d'un oral aussi le baccalauréat a connu
sa révolution le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a présenté cette semaine sa
réforme de l'examen
pour en parler nous recevrons hauts
plateaux delphine romagny responsable
dans les yvelines du syndicat snes dans
le reste de l'actualité retour sur la
mobilisation des syndicats de justice au
tribunal de grande instance de
versailles ou encore une journée sur les
métiers en uniforme attrape soutenir le
commerce de proximité face à la
concurrence des centres commerciaux et
des grandes surfaces et donc l'ambition
de la ville de maurepas la commune a mis
en place depuis mars dernier un fonds d
aide à la reprise et à la rénovation des
devantures commerciales une enveloppe
globale de 15000 euros a alloué tous les
ans ce jeudi le maire de la ville a
rendu visite à la première boutique qui
a profité de cette subvention reportage
de miquel et demi d'euros et grégory
canal et alors on a créé un stickers qui
officialise le fait qu'on vous aider
c'est pas comme ça ça montre que
la ville vous accompagner dans vos
démarches un nouveau propriétaire et une
nouvelle devanture ce dépôt de pain a
été repris en septembre puis ouvert en
décembre dans le quartier des coudrais à
maurepas
il a bénéficié d'une enveloppe de 3000
euros accordés par la ville
les fonds ont permis de changer
totalement l'ancienne façade composée à
présent d'huisseries rouge est dotée
d'une nouvelle enseigne attiré l'oeil
des habitants objectif pour ce commerce
qui sert une quarantaine de clients par
jour on en avait un petit peu besoin
malgré tout les font qu'on a investi
dedans c'est une aide qu'on accepte et
que ça fait plaisir c'est la première
boutique à profiter de ce genre de
subventions à maurepas grâce à cette
aide elle va pouvoir tourner ses
investissements vers d'autres besoins le
dépôt de pain souhaitait s'équiper
prochainement d'un four et d'un frigo
qui vont pouvoir certainement engager
d'autres font ailleurs pour investir
pour se diversifier et ça permet
également de soutenir le commerce de
proximité dans le sens où de les aider à
s'implanter à rénover leurs devantures
donc avoir une meilleure allure
esthétique
donc tout ça joue aussi dans l'aspect
urbain à faire en sorte de dynamiser les
commerces de proximité se fondent aide à
la reprise et à la rénovation des
devantures commerciales va concerner
chaque année cinq boutiques à maurepas
l'enveloppent de 15000 euros et
renouveler cette année c'est un symbole
voire un mythe de l'éducation nationale
en france lancée par napoléon il ya plus
de deux siècles le baccalauréat sera
donc largement réformée à partir de 2021
dans les grandes lignes la nouvelle
réforme prévoit la mise en place de
contrôles continus d'un oral en
terminale et de quatre épreuves écrites
dont deux spécialités choisies par les
élèves
adieu aussi les séries s es et l
une véritable transformation de l'examen
et du lycée porté par jean michel blanc
car le ministre de l'éducation nationale
et qui arrive forcément avec son lot de
questions et d'inquiétudes
écoutez à ce propos ces quelques
réactions recueillies à saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est vrai que même nous quand on est un
petit peu plus vieux les oraux ça nous
fait un peu stressé donc je vous
avouerai que 17 18 ans c'est pas
forcément la bonne solution
ce qu'on n'est pas forcément de beaucoup
préparé à l'oral c'est plus de l'écrit
vous faire alors à la presse pas tout le
monde qui est à l'aise à l'oral fait du
coup ça peut aussi mettre des certaines
personnes ont elles aussi vite et ça
fait pas de mal de dépoussiérer de temps
en temps aussi un peu ce qu'on sait pas
c'est une institution qui bon parfois
c'est un peu on est un peu sceptiques
sont certains une année où il ya des
résultats qui sont formidables pour tout
le monde et puis oui je pense que c'est
bien de d'essayer d'améliorer mais bon
voilà on fait toujours essayer ça permet
une liberté dans finalement à l'élève de
choisir ce qu'il a envie plutôt que au
final choisir entre trois filières et
qui est des matières imposé à moi je
trouve qu'on a de l'ambition on essaie
de faire quelque chose de nouveau et je
trouve ça intéressant et pour parler de
cette réforme en profondeur
nous sommes avec delphine romani en
plateau bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes la
secrétaire départementale du syndicat
national des enseignements de second
degré aussi appelé le snes c'est plus
simple et pour évoquer cette réforme du
bac et votre syndicat avait un avis
plutôt tranché à partir de mercredi
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu entendre
dans ce micro trottoir dans le
communiqué de presse les mots qui était
employé c'était complexe désarticulé
inégalitaire clairement c'est une
mauvaise réforme pour vous alors oui
nous nous pensons c'est une réforme qui
surtout est profondément inégalitaire
qui va instaurer une forme de tri social
que nous contestons et que c'est
également une réforme qui est piloté par
des impératifs qui sont essentiellement
des impératifs budgétaires
pourquoi inégalitaire c'est le volet
surtout contrôle continu qui va qui va
creuser les inégalités selon vous alors
ya effectivement le volet contrôle
continu qui va nécessairement créer des
inégalités entre les établissements
puisque à partant du principe que les
établissements n'ont pas tous le même
niveau
voilà exactement c'est ça c'est ça le
fond du problème mais aussi je pense
qu'on va rentrer un petit peu dans le
détail des choix qui vont pouvoir faire
les élèves et on sait aussi que suivant
la taille des établissements suivants
les enseignants qui sont déjà en poste
dans ces établissements
l'offre des fameux parcours ne sera pas
la même et que ça créera forcément des
disparités entre
les différents lycées le ministère de
l'éducation et son ex ministre jean
michel blanquer lui assure depuis
mercredi qu' il y aura une harmonisation
de d'assurer vous contestez ça vous dit
forcément des différents selon les
lycées les territoires alors en fait ce
qu'il dit c'est qu'il y aura des
parcours qui vont être cadré
nationalement et que ensuite avec ce
qu'on appelle la marge c'est à dire des
heures dont les établissements disposent
et dont ils font ce qu'ils veulent
à partir de cette marge on pourra
proposer d'autres parcours donc
nécessairement il y aura des offres
différentes et qui seront variables
suivant les établissements les moyens
pardon dans les établissements disposent
pour rappel alors il y aura 40 % de
notes en contrôle continu 60% en
épreuves finales dont le fameux orale
qui préoccupe beaucoup aussi
alors là aussi je reprends les propos un
peu faire pour faire contre balancier du
ministre qui dit qu'en substance cet
oral ça permettra de combler les
inégalités justement puisqu'il servira à
tous que tout le monde pour aller
préparer pendant deux ans sur un projet
première terminale et qu'il sera du coup
profitable à tous pour la vie future est
ce que c'est pas un raisonnement qui se
comprend et qui se justifie largement
cet oral là alors le fait qu'il y à un
oral au bac
oui pourquoi pas c'est c'est une chose
intéressante après ce conseil les jeunes
de votre reportage le disent très bien
ils disent que ils sont stressés il y
avait un jeune homme qui disait
également que l'on n'était pas forcément
bien préparés à cette cet exercice et
nous aussi ce que nous disons c'est que
rien dans les projets du ministre ne
sont dits par exemple sur le travail en
groupes à effectifs réduits et donc tant
qu'on n'a pas les moyens matériels aussi
de travailler l'oral ça devient une
difficulté et finalement c'est ce qu'il
maîtrise déjà les codes de l'oral qui
sont favorisés que c'est de bien
préparer cet oral c'est ce que vous
dites c'est d'avoir les moyens pour
préparer les élèves à cet oral alors oui
la grande interrogation c'est de quels
moyens ce qu'on va disposer pour le
préparer
évidemment c'est de la poudre aux yeux
si on dispose pas de réels moyens et
effectivement ce qu'on sait c'est que
c'est qu'au delà sont très socialement
marqué et la crainte que l'on a c'est
que effectivement ce soit en fonction de
leur profil sociologique que les élèves
soient plus ou moins avantagés alors
l'autre réforme importante de cette de
ce bac là c'est la fin des séries s es
et l et la mise en place du coup de
d'options facultatives de spécialités
que l'on que l'on pourrait choisir
il y aura un tronc commun et puis il y
aura des des spécialités les élèves
pourront piocher dans trois matières en
première de matières ans en terminale on
a entendu l'un des élèves justement la
réaction qui disait c'est bien ça laisse
de la liberté aux élèves de pouvoir
choisir leurs matières vous qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ça à cet argument
aussi qui est avancé qu'on
responsabilise les élèves face à leurs
futurs leur choix futurs alors nous ce
qu'on dit hostas alors d'une parce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que cette
réforme elle est articulée avec la
réforme de l'accès au supérieur et
course par course hupin et que donc avec
parcours sur ont défini un certain
nombre d' attendu et que ce sont ses
attendus qui vont permettre aux élèves
de rentrer ou non dans certaines
filières universitaires qu'ils ont
choisi et que les parcours introduisent
la nécessité de faire les bons choix dès
le lycée pour être ensuite accepté dans
la bonne filière et que faire un choix
précoce parfois dès la classe de seconde
peut être excessivement compliqué soit
pour un élève qui est un petit peu
immature soit pour un élève qui vient
d'un milieu social où on n'a pas les
codes et et dont les parents vont avoir
de la difficulté à comprendre un petit
peu et à se diriger dans les arcanes de
ce système scolaire qui peut paraître
assez compliqué est ce que ça veut dire
que pour votre syndicat le bac c'était
quelque chose qui marchait bien la
seconde la première la terminale aussi
qu'il n'y avait finalement rien à faire
ou alors vous étiez d'accord aussi sur
cette réforme voulue
même si vous n'aviez pas les mêmes
propositions j'ai bien compris
alors nous on a des propositions sur le
bac alors en effet nous ce que l'on
pense c'est que le bac tel qu'il existe
actuellement
évidemment doit doit être réformé
mais que l'organisation en série permet
de définir une forme de culture comme
unique qui encadrent collectivement les
jeunes et c'est la nation en propre en
proposant un cadre national qui va
permettre aux jeunes les plus fragiles
les plus socialement défavorisés de
profiter d'un cadre qui va les empêcher
de faire des choix trop précoce ou qui
serait pas forcément bien avisée donc ça
c'est ce qu'on pense ces choix là si je
comprends bien c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour ceux qui savent déjà ce qu'ils vont
faire qui en sont persuadés et pour ceux
qui se posent des questions ça pourrait
être un piège d'avoir autant d'options
possibles et de devoir choisir
tout à fait et ce qu'il faut pas oublier
aussi c'est que donc le la commission
mathiot qui a et qui a consulté sur le
projet de réforme du baccalauréat du
lycée n'a pas du tout examiné la
question du lycée professionnel qui
était il ya une réflexion il ya une
répression en plus pour le lycée
professionnel et donc évidemment nous on
ne déplore puisqu'en fait ça veut dire
que les bacheliers professionnels qui
sont des bacheliers comme les autres et
qu'on renonce en fait à donner une forme
de culture commune à tous nos jeunes
qu'ils soient pas chez les
professionnels technologiques ou
généraux et nous on est très attaché à
cette idée de culture commune qui permet
à chaque jeune en fait d'être en quelque
sorte pris en charge par la nation et
qui lui donne une culture une base
commune qui doit être partagé par tous
pour revenir sur cette voie générale il
y aura donc un socle commun tout de même
qui comprend par exemple 1 le français
l'histoire géographie les langues
vivantes le sport et puis il y aura donc
dix options il faudra en choisir trois
ans 1re 2 en terminale parmi celles ci
des noms qu'on n'a pas l'habitude
d'entendre au lycée numérique et
sciences informatiques a aussi
histoire-géographie géopolitique et
science politique ça c'est une matière
commune
est-ce que ça va aussi est ce que vous
vous craignez que ça change aussi votre
métier avoue d'enseignants est ce que
est ce que les profs s'interrogent sur
leur avenir aussi
alors oui bien sûr l épreuve
s'interrogent sur leur avenir alors en
ce qui concerne ses enseignements
nouveau ne sait pas encore par qui ils
vont sur la grille en charge la région
politique on ne sait pas on imagine
probablement les professeurs
d'histoire-géo mais au moins il va
peut-être falloir songer à les former
après on est là on a vraiment aucune
indication pour l'instant sur le contenu
des programmes 1 le ministère a passé
commande au csp au conseil supérieur de
l'éducation pour la rédaction des
programmes donc on a relativement peu de
peu de peu d'indication là-dessus
ce qu'on peut dire aussi c'est sûr sur
la partie commune des de la voie
générale
c'était un grand absent ce sont les
mathématiques est ce que justement
j'allais vous pour vous poser encore une
question est ce qu'il ya des professeurs
de certaines matières qui s'inquiète
peut-être de ne pas de disparaître mais
d'être moins importante on pense aux
mathes holà aux sciences et vie de la
terre est ce que vous avez cessé
remonter la du terrain qui vous disent
attention nous qu'est ce qu'on va faire
plus tard les élèves vont peut-être plus
nous pratiques et oui tout à fait alors
y avait des fortes inquiétudes aussi de
la part des professeurs de sciences de
sciences de la vie et de la terre qui
étaient dans le cortège de la
manifestation du 6 février justement
autour de tout c'est toutes ces
questions là plus de mal dans le tronc
commun plus de sciences expérimentales
qui pourtant devrait faire partie de la
culture commune les sciences de la vie
et de la terre les sciences physiques
bon les élèves non plus dans leur tronc
commun ils devront choisir s'ils veulent
de suivre donc
en effet je pense que c'est assez assez
inquiétant pour les profs qui enseignent
ces disciplines delphine remaniée rester
en plateau on va passer tout de suite à
l'actualité de la semaine
une semaine placée est décidément sur le
signe de l'éducation mercredi la ville
de montigny le bretonneux organisé une
nuit dédiée à l'orientation l'occasion
d'aider et de guider les étudiants qui
s'interroge à propos notamment de la
nouvelle plateforme parcours sup pour
rentrer à l'université sujet de camille
lambert test d'orientation informations
sur les études et les métiers échanges
avec des conseillers trouver un métier
qui lui correspond ressemble parfois à
un parcours du combattant
et même quand on pense avoir découvert
sa voie certains s'aperçoivent que cela
ne leur correspond pas
c'est le cas de florent qui souhaitent
changer de filière et abb j'ai adhéré à
l'université j'ai fait ma première année
du coup j'ai redoublé et là je décroche
complètement et j'aimerais du comment
réorienter c'est pour ça que j'ai fait
questionnaire à un questionnaire qui le
confirme dans ses choix audiovisuel ou
les sciences pour eva actuellement en
première c'est encore un peu flou une
période qu'elle juge stressante
il y en a qui savent pas du tout quoi
faire et puis enfin non mais des fois
beaucoup trop la pression peut-être pour
savoir ce qu'on va faire alors que je
pense qu'il ya pas besoin de mettre tant
la pression que ça au bout d'un moment
on va bien trouver sa voie et on va
savoir ce qu'on voudrait faire plus
simple
c'est justement pour apaiser les
angoisses des collégiens lycéens mais
aussi de leurs parents que le pôle
jeunesse a organisé cette nuit de
l'orientation un moment voulu convivial
cette année on a mis en place des choses
un peu plus interactive et aussi une
animation escape game qui est ludique et
qui tourne aussi autour du thème des
métiers de l'orientation pour aussi
désamorcer
le sujet plus rapide et efficace je dois
gérer le stress lié à mon poste de
travail
d'autres rendez vous de ce type sont
organisées plusieurs fois par an pour
venir se renseigner le pôle jeunesse est
ouvert tous les jours delphine romani
ces annonces autour de l'examen du
baccalauréat suivent à quelques jours
près celle autour de parcours sur cette
nouvelle plateforme pour entrer à
l'université est ce qu'on peut au moins
reconnaître au gouvernement une certaine
logique une certaine continuité dans les
idées vous disiez vous même tout à
l'heure cette nouvelle réforme du bac je
suis finalement par course va aider
peut-être à mieux s'insérer à
l'université ce que vous partagez ce au
point de vue ou alors pas du tout alors
effectivement il ya une grande cohérence
dans les annonces de réformes qui ont
été faites par le gouvernement la
réforme du lycée elle est vraiment
complètement pensé à la suite de ce qui
a été prévu pour parcours sup
malheureusement elle obéit donc selon
nous à une logique de tri social qui au
contraire au lieu de mieux permettre aux
élèves de suivre des études
universitaires à l'étrier les
sélectionnés et contraindre certains à
renoncer à suivre des études supérieures
merci delphine romani d'être venu sur le
plateau de tv 78 je rappelle que vous
êtes la responsable du snes fsu dans les
yvelines syndicats d'enseignants merci à
vous et bon week-end merci mon week-end
à vous une première depuis 2011 jeudi
toutes les professions de la justice
étaient mobilisés à l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats l'action se place en
opposition au projet de réforme lancée
par la ministre et garde des sceaux
nicole belloubet des rassemblements se
tenait partout en france comme à
versailles
reportage au tribunal de grande instance
de marylène ya piccino les neuf
organisations syndicales des métiers de
la justice ne s'était pas unis depuis
seulement face au projet gouvernemental
de réforme
la mobilisation s'impose pour les
syndicats mot d'ordre est justice de
qualité
la garde des sceaux mme belloubet a
décidé de mettre en place cinq chantiers
pour rénover l'institution
judiciaire et au vu des rapports qui ont
été déposés elle nous a demandé quels
étaient les lignes rouges à ne pas
franchir et il se trouve que les
professionnels de la justice que sont
les fonctionnaires les magistrats les
avocats ont décidé ces neuf
organisations ont décidé de se
rassembler pour dire nous ne voulons pas
sur la base des propositions qui sont
faites
la réforme que vous pensez nous proposer
les syndicats parlent de déficit humains
matériels et immobilier selon eux une
centaine de magistrats manque à la cour
d'appel de versailles
les pannes informatiques vont perdre un
temps difficiles à rattraper et les
locaux sont vétustes
ici à versailles tout à chacun peut
passer devant le palais de justice et
voir qu'il ya un grand filet qui protège
le bâtiment parce que nous n'avons même
plus les moyens de maintenir nos murs en
état nous avons pour informer les
citoyens et parler de ses mouvements au
sens de la justice
les syndicats ont prévu de mettre en
place des réunions publiques dans les
yvelines dans les jours à venir
le calendrier n'est pas encore fixée
mais le projet est quant à lui bien
établie la ligne 18 du grand paris
express permettra de relier à terme
l'aéroport d'orly à versailles 35 km de
métro qui passeront notamment en aérien
sur le plateau de saclay un tronçon qui
inquiète certains élus et associations
impact environnemental économique ou
encore agricole et préoccupations sont
nombreuses les détails avec ce reportage
c'est un peu le combat de david contre
goliath
quatre communes et huit associations du
plateau de saclay opposé ensemble à un
projet de plusieurs milliards d'euros
porté par l'état et les principaux élus
du territoire
un combat qu'il mène principalement
depuis la déclaration d'utilité publique
de la ligne 18 il y a un an lorsque l'on
regarde donc être public qui a été menée
dans le détail on s'aperçoit très bien
qu'il ya toute une partie de l'anc a
public qui a été de l'avis des gens qui
ont été quand ils étaient auditionnés
qui a été écartée ou interprétés c'est
là où on s'aperçoit que la société du
grand paris a essayé de masquer
la vider les gens pour faire passer son
projet trop cher trop dangereuses pour
l'environnement est inefficace pour
répondre aux besoins du plateau de
saclay élus et associations locaux ont
déposé en tout deux recours devant le
conseil d'état
leurs espoirs se faire entendre sur
leurs propositions
tous les alternatives qui aurait pu être
notamment des transports innovants sous
forme de petits véhicules ou des
téléphériques etc tous ces projets là
ils ont été étouffés ils ont été tués
dans l'oeuf
on a tous privilégié sur la ligne 18
personnes ne connaît véritablement le
dossier technique
or nous ce dossier technique nous
l'avons largement étudiés et nous savons
qu'il ya des possibilités autres qui
coûterait beaucoup moins cher et qui
serait beaucoup plus facile à mettre en
oeuvre des idées et des projets que les
élus du plateau de saclay pourront
présenter lors d'un rendez vous à
matignon le 22 mars prochain
c'est en mars aussi que le gouvernement
doit enfin annoncé le nouveau calendrier
de grand paris express
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour beaucoup
la communauté emmaüs de trappes va
rouvrir ses portes début mars un an et
demi après avoir fermé un retour
nécessaire comme l'expliqué franck les
tons le responsable local dans notre
journal
mercredi soir ils locaux n'étaient pas
adaptés donc il a fallu prendre le temps
justement de tous
cette interruption pour retravailler un
projet en lien aussi avec emmaüs france
qui est beaucoup intervenu dans la
réflexion est aussi dans un soutien
économique à remonter ce projet comment
ça a été possible justement dhr la
rouverture il ya eu un rachat des locaux
notamment je crois alors on a racheté
les louent des locaux on a ensuite
effectué les travaux nécessaires à
l'amélioration de l'outil et puis puis
voilà des choses se sont faites tout
simplement avec des bénévoles qui se
sont mobilisés durant ces deux ans
autour d'une réflexion et puis des
salariés dont je fais partie d'emmaüs
france qui ont importé
voilà la fois leur expérience et puis
aussi leur expertise dans le reste de
l'actualité mardi la cité des métiers de
saint quentin en yvelines organisé un
forum d'information sur les métiers en
uniforme événement dédié au secteur de
la défense et de la sécurité publique
une trentaine de professionnels du
secteur étaient présents sur place
camille lambert et quentin le frère
[Musique]
analyser une scène de crime relever les
empreintes
loin de l'image véhiculée par les séries
télé emmanuel montre la réalité
quotidienne de la police scientifique et
de faire ce qu'on appelle des recherches
de traces qu en général de douaouda des
ailes au niveau des vols par effraction
des petits cambriolages souvent des
jeunes sont attirés par ce qu'ils
pensent qu'on peut faire et du terrain
trouvé tout de suite des scènes assez
impressionnant tout ça va amener des
lavoirs et interroger les suspects etc
ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas de notre
métier nous aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
segmenté il ya des personnes qui vont
faire des prélèvements
les personnes qui vont faire les
et les analyses et des personnes qui
vont faire l'anc est un forum pour
découvrir et comprendre les métiers liés
à la sécurité
lycéens et collégiens se sont rendus à
la cité des métiers de saint quentin en
yvelines pour s'informer je suis au gsp
depuis deux ans déjà et je voulais
m'orienter tard pour savoir comment
faire pour être pompier professionnel
dans l'armée on a convié une trentaine
de professionnels qu'on peut rencontrer
aujourd'hui issus de dix corps de métier
donc on est parti quand même du besoin
de deux de ces corps de métier les
services pénitentiaires avaient la
police nationale qui nous ont contactés
pour nous faire part de leurs
difficultés de recrutement cette année
la police nationale espère recruter 1000
jeunes sans condition de diplôme en
france plus de 3000 gardiens de la paix
et 2000 surveillants pénitentiaires sont
recherchés pour terminer cette émission
une idée de sortie pour votre week-end
avec la réouverture du parc de thoiry
c'est samedi l'occasion de rencontrer
son nouveau pensionnaire le jeune
rhinocéros unesco arrivé fin janvier est
de faire aussi le plein de nouveautés et
de sensations reportage de camille
lambert
à peine âgée de 3 ans unesco pèse déjà
près de deux tonnes arrivé le 25 janvier
c'est l'une de ses premières sorties
avec ses compagnons il découvre sa
nouvelle maison et ses voisins
son arrivée depuis le safari de peaugres
en ardèche est un symbole fort pour le
parc qui se remet doucement de la mort
de vince il y a un an
unesco et à thoiry pour grandir dans
quelques années ils pourraient aider à
préserver son espèce la mère de l'unesco
à gestantes et va mettre bas au mois de
mars
et donc il fallait que ce jeu de mal un
kit quitte son groupe d'origine
donc il va rester là quelques années si
le coordinateur du programme de 2
d'élevage des rhinocéros en europe a
besoin de lui en reproduction dans un
autre parc
effectivement il pourrait repartir dans
quelques années pour s'accoupler avec
une certaine semaine mais pas de
naissance de rhinau prévu à thoiry
unesco partage son box avec bruno un
mâle de cinq ans et grassi la doyenne de
37 ans les visiteurs pourront le
rencontrer dès le 17 février et
découvrir les autres nouveautés du parc
l'offre d'activités aérienne initiée
avec la tyrolienne du côté des lions a
été complété par un parcours dans les
arbres où on va évoluer dans des filets
jusqu'à 9 mètres de hauteur avec une vue
sur les animaux de la plaine africaine
il ya eu dix semaines de montage dans
les arbres pour pouvoir accrocher ses
filets donc c'est vraiment une aventure
bondissante
on peut y aller à partir de 3 ans
accompagnés d'un adulte bien sûr le parc
de thoiry fête cette année ses 50 ans
pour l'occasion une nouvelle zone
d'immersion est en création
un trek australiens avec une volière
d'oiseaux exotiques et un parcours au
milieu des wallabies sera prêt pour le
printemps
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo autour
de l'actualité en direct lundi à 18h sur
l'antenne de tva 78 d'ici là restez
connectés et informés grâce à notre site
internet
nos réseaux sociaux et l'application tv
78 aussi bons au ghana tous et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]